Today we are going to see how AI research
is changing the landscape of gaming,
videoconferencing, robotics, and so much more.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Now, first - here, we usually talk about papers.
This is not a paper. So you will see results
that we cannot evaluate as thoroughly as we
normally do with peer-reviewed research. However,
I still think it is important to talk about
because even though this is not paper,
but it is Papers coming to life
in the world around us. You see,
these technologies appeared or will appear
in products that millions of Fellow Scholars
are going to use all around the world,
so I would like to show them to you.
And I will note that we have
no business ties with NVIDIA.
Now, here they talked about HybridAI, where
your local graphics card will do one part
of the computation, and a different part
will be streamed from the cloud. So, why?
Well, for instance, noise removal for your
videoconferencing should run locally on your
machine as it requires low latency, it cannot
wait for the cloud to do all this. There is not
enough time for that. But Photoshop’s generative
fill can take a little longer in the cloud to
ensure it runs on a smarter AI model, and
give you your text to image results here.
Okay, so these are the local and cloud models.
What is this hybrid thing? Well, consider their
previous work on creating virtual characters with
generative AI. Earlier, they showcased a system
which can automatically come up with dialogue
for a virtual character in a video game. First,
the text what the character needs to say will be
synthesized by an AI, then a text to voice AI will
make it actually say it in a human voice, and the
mouth movements will also be synthesized. Look.
It sounded a little stiff, could have been a
bit more natural, but this is only the first
version of something that was previously nearly
impossible. So here’s the breakdown. When you
talk to a virtual character, your local voice
input is transcribed locally, this then goes
into a large language model in the cloud, when
we got the text response from the game character,
speech is synthesized in the cloud, and then,
it comes back to your machine where the lip
syncing is done quickly and locally. And all
this happens without you noticing all this
wizardry. That is quite impressive. And this
is available for developers to use right now.
We can also use generative AI to create these
virtual characters themselves too. Like the video
game characters from this earlier video, they can
all be given an identity and a backstory and like
good little actors, they will pretend to be this
person. They can even become a Fellow Scholar.
Now at this point my reaction was
that I’d love to see that in action
in this framework and luckily,
that’s exactly what happened.
Now these characters are much more true to life,
and it gets better, every time you enter the room,
the conversation will be different. All
synthesized on the fly. If the occasion
calls for it, words are connected to actions
as well, and you might get a drink for free.
Also, more games will come with RTX
technology, with AI-based ray tracing,
supersampling, antialiasing, you name it. All in
the name of better visual quality for
virtual worlds. These look fantastic.
And during March, ray tracing is also coming to
Diablo 4. And RTX Remix will help you remaster
previous games and add ray tracing effects
to it and upscale old and blocky textures.
If you ask me, anything that can make the Portal
game better is good news in my book, and also,
hold on to your crowbars, Fellow Scholars and
check out this glorious this Half-Life 2 remix.
Their new text to image AI is also out, this
can perform not only the usual image from
text prompts, but we can also add these masks to
apply the prompt to only a subset of the image,
extend the image, and more. Note that
these tools also exist elsewhere,
and also that this is a paid
service, and before you pay,
free and open source techniques, for
instance, Stable Diffusion also exist.
If you watch Twitch, where you can
watch a stream of someone playing games,
the quality of these streams
can be enhanced with RTX cards.
Oh yes, cards. A new series of graphics
cards, the super-series was also announced,
I love these animations in which they
introduce them. This one looks like it
is coming straight from outer space. This
has more CUDA cores and more memory for
faster generative AI. New RTX laptops are also
coming. If you can, always look up independent
benchmarks for the particular application
you intend to use them for before buying.
Now, we already know that AI is infusing these
robots in more and more warehouses and factories,
but now they are also permeating agriculture,
construction, healthcare, and retail as well.
Due to GPT, these robots now understand our
commands significantly better. And don’t forget,
a virtual version of these factories
can be modeled by a generative AI,
which is kinda mind blowing, and now
these robots can train in these virtual
environments to make sure they are safe
before being deployed in the real world.
And in a simulation, we can also do
tons and tons of domain randomization,
apply changes to these virtual worlds to make
sure these AIs are safe and work properly
in any kind of situation. This used to take
professional artists and days and days of work,
now it runs in a matter of minutes and just
text prompts are needed. And we can now tell
them to shake hands, lie down or nod
their heads. This will lead to smarter
vacuum cleaners and lawn mowing robots
and so much more. What a time to be alive!